et c'est une fille Daisy et il y a la
fille d'anniversaire fromage bonjour
Maryville c'est un début froid pour la journée en
ce moment seulement 21 degrés Audrey était l'une
de mes seules vraies amies elle a toujours été une
enfant heureuse et amusante et Daisy elle était
une fille à papa  dans une petite ville tout le monde
est connecté beaucoup de ces familles
sont ici depuis des générations
ce gars a commencé à m'envoyer des SMS c'était un
peu comme Oh les garçons plus âgés veulent passer du temps
avec nous je pense que j'étais ivre les garçons
étaient assez persistants alors je suppose que les
choses  a empiré elle était allongée dans la
cour et ses cheveux étaient gelés jusqu'au
sol un groupe de garçons se pressait
autour d'un téléphone vous l'avez portée à l'
étage s'est évanoui pourquoi avez-vous menti à
la police
elle a dit j'ai peur j'ai fait quelque chose que
je  Je ne voulais pas faire qui a pris la vidéo,
toute la ville s'est séparée et décide
Daisy
contre des gens très très
vicieux, nous avons commencé à avoir des problèmes de
vandalisme, cela a été repris dans le monde
des médias sociaux, c'est à ce moment-là que cela a
éclaté  une tempête de feu au petit-fils d'un
fonctionnaire du Missouri s'est libérée
notre maison a été incendiée ce sont
des cas très difficiles pas de belle façon de dire à leur
vie le verdict est difficile à croire elle a
dit que je ne peux plus faire ça
est devenu plus important pour protéger  les
garçons qu'il n'a fait pour trouver justice pour les
filles essaient mr.  Les filles Eakins ont autant de
culpabilité dans ce monde que les garçons si
personne n'en parle alors je le ferai
c'est triste mais après ça on envoie
quelque chose de cliqué je ne peux pas ignorer une armée
de voix les mots de nos ennemis
ne sont pas aussi affreux  comme le silence de
référence